hello and welcome to this video was the
Amagi 1919 smile pod
she got a Rossum Nemo okay
I had one game before I came out with
this one
careful Queen c7 is what they usually do
g6 a g6 is odd it's really a bit of an
odd news because then a six looks like
wow really
okay allowing a5 is a is a really
strange decision because now the whole
black pawn structure is totally totally
wasted
well it's winning already okay um do I
win more material you can win each five
now two pawns let's think about this for
a moment I really don't want to give him
any sort of hope so let's go here the
knight cannot move the bishop cannot
move our sixes hanging so now
[Music]
fine
this is also not too bad
95 Bishop takes f6 is probably
okay yeah many just didn't care about
the opening it seems like a six is not
good
taking on c6 is an option for white
anyway and he often does said unprovoked
yeah here the interesting move is Queen
to c7 which is intending to play e5
right away after which I go away for a 5
and D form and I think white is a bit
better but it's an interesting position
still yeah g6 and I mean that this
doesn't add up simply and here you have
to go away 5 just just forced you cannot
allow a 5 I'm surprised that the engine
is giving anything else and now it got
down there are b6 maybe b6 but a 5 is
almost strategically mandatory to
prevent the area portico from ever like
here after this it's basically over as
you cannot ever get discovered in a
decent way
I mean 97 is the next mistake he has to
try to get the Knight to d7 to cover it
only 7 that is just looking at bad
squares and here this is just gone the
pawn is gone I cannot cover it and white
wins yeah it's really nothing much
happening it's just a complete win and
therefore and yeah okay 26 wasn't
helpful but he's got no move anyway I'm
threatening the check and to take on f6
that's it yeah okay guys thanks so much